6 24 on your monday morning how about
learning a lot more about las vegas
boulevard in front of resorts world
by going to baggage claim at mccarran
airport
well yeah you will be able to check off
several junior buddy boxes
after this hanging out unobtrusively
next to carousel
six in the terminal one baggage claim
is this very cool architectural model
of the entire resorts world complex
we can talk more about the pool on the
south side of the tower or the employee
parking overlooking the d.i super
arterial
but for today las vegas boulevard in
front of resorts world
now clark county has indicated that
starting the day of the opening next
thursday the 24th
running all the way to july 5th
southbound drivers on the strip will
have all lanes open directly next to the
project
and at least two lanes from sahara south
of spring mountain
also two lanes for northbounders except
for overnight from 2 a.m to 10 a.m
but the real point of today's story
projected
locations for not one but two pedestrian
bridges
one over di the other further north
coming out from around the middle of the
building's east side
so go ahead check off your junior
traffic buddy
junior architect buddy and junior
resorts world buddy boxes there you go
now we know the location of the
pedestrian bridges but no
timeline just yet keep it right here for
all your resorts world updates they're
also available 24 7
on our website and you can find the
online version of this and all our
stories at eightnewsnow.com when you
click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic8newsnow.com